on est aujourd'hui un vivatech alors je
sais pas si vous connaissez vivatex
c'est le grand salon en France qui va
parler de technologie d'innovation de
technologie globale et là on est
aujourd'hui présent en partenariat avec
EDF qui m'a dit drôle viens nous voir
viens sur notre stand euh ma vivatech et
tu vas voir il y a plein de choses qui
se passe pourquoi parce que on connaît
tous EDF comme fournisseur d'énergie qui
est là depuis tellement longtemps
historique on connaît on aime vous êtes
abonné peut-être pas en tout cas tout le
monde connaît les sauf que EDF et bien
il cherche des solutions d'avenir
notamment avec des start-up vous allez
voir c'est super cool vidéo éducative
intéressante et moi préparer le sujet
j'ai dit mais je savais même pas que EDF
faisait ça je suis extrêmement bluffé
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment dans les commentaires est-ce
que vous allez être autant bleu avec moi
en tout cas on part en immersion tout de
suite avivatec ici premier jour Viva
tech et vous allez pas être au bout de
vos surprises
la première c'est une boîte qui
s'appelle switch energy alors
accrochez-vous c'est une production
d'énergie création d'énergie totalement
révolutionnaire en fait je vous explique
comment ça se passe vous avez une
membrane et d'un côté de la membrane
vous avez de l'eau qui n'est pas salé de
l'autre côté vous avez de l'eau salée et
par en échange du haut de l'eau salée
vers l'eau qui n'est pas salée et bien
la membrane va être en capacité de créer
de l'énergie on se parle donc ici d'un
transfert du jour à travers cette
salinité qui permet de fabriquer de
l'énergie alors je vais pas rentrer dans
goûter un peu trop technique parce que
même moi d'une je ne le maîtrise pas on
me l'a expliqué mais c'est quand même
relativement complexe parce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que à travers cette
membrane vous avez des ports et le fait
de faire passer de l'eau salée vers de
l'eau passe à lait ça ne change
osmotique et qui vous permet de créer de
l'énergie alors ça c'est génial il y a
plusieurs usages le premier c'est qu'ils
ont créé grâce à ça un objet c'est cette
espèce de petite machine là petit grosse
machine vous allez venir l'installer au
niveau d'un estuaire vous allez avoir de
l'eau qui va pas être chargé en sel et
de l'autre côté l'océan vous allez avoir
de l'eau qui va être chargé en scène et
grâce à cette membrane et bien vous
allez pouvoir venir créer cette énergie
alors après nous dit ici l'équipe de
switch énergie c'est que vous allez
apporter 1% de sel à l'eau qui n'est pas
salée donc les rejets sont globalement
minimes mais ça ne pose absolument aucun
problème on se parle donc ici d'une
énergie décarbonée on se parlant au même
si d'une énergie propre qui permettra de
fournir de l'énergie alors ta partie
d'un mix énergétique à l'idée c'est pas
de se dire on va venir révolutionner et
faire que de l'énergie grâce à ce
système là mais venir apporter dans le
mix énergétique ils vont beaucoup plus
loin parce qu'ils viennent se projeter à
15-20 ans et à 15-20 ans l'idée c'est de
venir créer cette espèce de grande
plateforme flottante alors sur le haut
ça flotte et après ça va à l'intérieur
d'exocéans alors je vous explique parce
que je savais pas et c'est vraiment
super intéressant c'est à dire que il y
a une différence de salinité entre le
haut de l'océan l'océan de la mer et le
bas plus vous allez en bas et plus l'eau
sera installée ici c'est pas de prendre
de l'eau qui va pas être salée et de
l'eau salée c'est de prendre de l'eau
moi salé de l'eau plus salée et grâce à
cette différence de salinité et bien
être en capacité de produire de
l'énergie grâce au système de membrane
c'est exactement le même système mais là
en fait vous auriez une plateforme
flottante elle vient pas s'installer on
vient pas la poser au fond des océans
donc on abîme pas les fonds marins donc
ça c'est une innovation française et
c'est une entreprise dans laquelle EDF
croit beaucoup et d'ailleurs il vient de
le présenter ici aujourd'hui à villattec
quand on produit de l'énergie il faut
bien la stopper quelque part et donc ici
on est sur une entreprise française qui
s'appelle Oliver l'énergie et qui crée
des systèmes de batterie des systèmes de
batterie différents déjà on se parle de
batterie française ça c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal et ça c'est bien et ça
nous plaît énormément mais surtout ici
la chimie va être différente on se parle
ici d'une batterie avec du lithium du
fer et des phosphates et on n'a pas de
cobaltes ici donc ça c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal et grâce à cette chimie
on va aller beaucoup plus loin au niveau
des cycles de charge là où avec des
batteries au COBAL vous avez peu près
12006 de charge et décharge ici vous
allez monter jusqu'à 4000 ça vous permet
donc d'aller beaucoup plus loin
d'emmener vos batteries beaucoup plus
loin et ça c'est bien c'est beau et
c'est bon pour l'environnement alors je
vous explique vous avez différentes
tailles de batterie ici on va se prendre
une batterie qui va être le plus petit
bien évidemment alors on aurait une pour
en avoir plusieurs ça va dépendre des
usages on se parle bien évidemment des
AST gros professionnel même si
potentiellement le particulier peut
l'avoir donc la petite format après on
va aller sur un format un peu plus grand
un format racable c'est celui-là que
vous avez ici donc là en fait vous allez
avoir deux unités de rack il y en a une
on peut en mettre plusieurs on les fait
communiquer par des RJ45 pour qu'elle
puisse se parler entre elles donc là
c'est pareil vous avez cette même chimie
et là il vous en met mis en voyant qui
permet de connaître votre niveau de
charge alors là vous voyez les full
patate mais par exemple vous allez voir
s'il va venir baisser si vous avez moins
d'énergie et le truc qui est cool c'est
que lorsqu'il est en charge et bien vous
allez voir il va monter donc vous pouvez
vraiment suivre la progression dans
votre niveau de batterie tout le temps
donc elle est raquée ok il y a pas de
mauvaise surprise vous savez toujours si
vous avez de l'énergie puis après
lorsqu'on va aller beaucoup plus loin et
on pense notamment par exemple et bien
aux Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent l'année
prochaine à Paris et bien lorsque vous
avez des gros besoins d'énergie au lieu
de venir faire tourner un groupe
électrogène qui va polluer qui est pas
bon qui est pas Green et qui ne plaît
pas et bien vous avez tous un système
qui nous propose ici qui lui va être
vert qui aura 7 chimie qui sera beaucoup
plus intéressante donc là le format que
vous avez c'est le format d'une palette
Europe donc vous pouvez la déplacer très
facilement vous avez votre triphasé en
rouge et votre monophasé en bas donc ça
répond vraiment des besoins extrêmement
précis tout ça une fois de plus sans
cobalt à base de lithium donc c'est une
boîte française qui fait ça c'est génial
parce que en plus de ça vous avez des
compétences françaises vous avez un SAV
français c'est chez nous pour cours et
cours bravo donc vous voyez il y a plein
de belles innovations et j'ai une
entreprise qui a gagné de dispositif EDF
pulse cette année et ça ça nous plaît et
là maintenant il y a un autre problème
qui est hyper important sur lequel et
bien ed vient travailler avec des
startups partenaires c'est le phénomène
de décarbonation notamment au niveau des
industries on sait que l'industries rien
que vous allez avoir elles émettent du
CO2 ça c'est pas bien ce qu'elle rejette
dans l'atmosphère et il y a tous les
problèmes de changement climatique
contrôlés et qu'on voit et ça c'est
globalement pas où donc ils sont dit ok
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
venir décarboner pour utiliser ces
rejets de CO2 et en faire quelque chose
plutôt que l'envoyer dans l'atmosphère
et bien c'est là où c'est intéressant
c'est que ils vont venir utiliser des
déchets qui sont produits pour pouvoir
ensuite grâce à une boîte qui s'appelle
carbonate pour pouvoir utiliser ce CO2
pour construire quelque chose avec et ne
pas le re dans l'atmosphère ils viennent
prendre un déchet un ciment et ils vont
venir alors par un procédé que je ne
vois plus je maîtrise pas c'est très
technique viennent prendre le ciment ils
viennent le mélanger avec du CO2 tout ça
en circuit fermé pour pouvoir venir nous
fabriquer un système de vie en fait
celui-là et bien c'est votre ciment et
votre CO2 qui est capturé à l'intérieur
donc déjà c'est pour avoir des montagnes
de billes ça servira globalement à rien
mais en fait c'est montagne de billes et
bien on peut en faire quelque chose de
très précis et c'est là que c'est super
intéressant donc prendre ses billes pour
venir fabriquer des bâtiments avec donc
ça une fois de plus c'est vertueux c'est
intelligent et c'est normal on est avec
Victor dans l'entreprise biziro carbone
qui serait un peu l'équivalent d'une
agence de notation comme standard pour
qui va garnoter notamment les États
comme la France vous vous notez les
entreprises par rapport au carbone on
est une agence de notation pour le
carbone volontaire donc on analyse les
projets qui émettent des des insectes
des crédits et on donne une notation sur
vraiment la carbone l'efficacité carbone
nous on est de marché a vraiment
comprendre la qualité de chacun des
projets OK et il y a plein de projets
dans le monde qui qui mettent des
crédits et nous on a une équipe de 5 ans
analyses tout spécialisés dans
différents domaines qui vont analyser
vraiment le projet et alors on va donner
notre avis d'expert sur la qualité
carbone du projet il y a vraiment
l'efficacité carbone est-ce que ce
crédit équivaut bien à une tonne de
carbone
enlevé de l'atmosphère pour le moment
vraiment ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
donc rajouter de la confiance au marché
et comment est-ce qu'on essaie la
mission finalement finale de baiser au
carbone c'est de diriger le capital vers
les meilleurs projets vers les projets
qui sont les mieux notés j'ai une autre
boîte qui est super intéressante qui est
hébergé sur le stand de EDF à bibataire
qui s'appelle
néoplan ça leur néoplan c'est une boîte
française qui va à Saint-Ouen qui fait
un truc qui est génial c'est que ils
font de la biotechnologie au niveau des
plantes c'est à dire qu'ils ont des
plantes ils vont venir modifier l'ADN
après je vais passer le côté un peu
technique ou j'ai acheté un peu de
soleil parce que le truc est vachement
bien c'est qu'on essaie le principe
d'une plante c'est à dire que une plante
elle dernier à capter le CO2 et elle va
créer de l'oxygène de l'eau de voilà ça
c'est le principe d'une plante c'est ce
qu'elle fait et d'ailleurs tout
l'oxygène que vous respirez vient des
plantes donc ces mots voilà ça c'est
pratique c'est la nature mais avec leur
techno ils ont beaucoup plus loin ils
viennent capter ce qu'on appelle les
vies aussi les voies océan l'avait aussi
c'est quoi et bien ça va être dans l'air
tous les solvants on va pouvoir
retrouver ça va être également les
peintures ça va être plein de produits
qui sont chez vous et donc vous ne
connaissez même pas l'existence est-ce
que va venir faire ici et bien les
plantes de l'entreprise des plantes elle
va venir en gros purifier l'air de façon
totalement naturelle là où une plante va
venir capter du CO2 et vous livrez de
l'eau deux et bien là il va venir capter
bien évidemment le CO2 mais capter
également sur l'appareil vit aussi pour
nettoyer l'air de votre intérieur on
trouve également dans le start-up sur le
stand 2DS qui est très long avec
notamment une entreprise suédoise qui
s'appelle cake et qui fabrique des motos
électriques alors là vous voyez vous
êtes sur le offrande vous êtes sur le
tout terrain avec une batterie qui est
planquée jusque là et surtout un design
qui est tout particulier et que
personnellement j'aime beaucoup ça très
minimaliste vous avez celle là c'est un
125 l'idée c'est d'aller se balader en
ville on parle vraiment de mobilité
urbaine on peut également l'avoir en
modèle draisienne pour aller sur les
pistes cyclables mais en petit 125 pour
se balader dans Paris ou ailleurs je
trouve ça assez joli puis l'idée c'est
qu'on peut venir également la customiser
changer différents éléments pour lui
donner un look qui va être un peu
affable et vous avez un autre modèle qui
est exposé c'est ce modèle là qui est
également à 125 pour un aller se balader
en ville qui est plutôt cool avec la
batterie qui est posée là on peut pas la
louper puis une fois de plus ce qui est
plutôt cool c'est le côté customisation
le côté on peut venir rajouter un siège
faudrait mettre un cadeau derrière pas
vous mettez le siège si vous voulez
enlever ça à mettre autre chose vous
pouvez donc vous voyez alors là il y a
pas d'innovation qui va vous
époustoufler par rapport à l'énergie
mais on les retrouve également sur le
stand EDF qui sont des matières on va
montrer aussi des Inno qui sont Green et
pourquoi pas des motos électriques et
pourquoi pas je vous ai montré quelques
entreprises qui sont partenaires de EDF
et que Def soutien et emmène ici
aujourd'hui à vivatech ça permet d'avoir
un peu cette vision d'avenir de
l'énergie comment est-ce qu'on vient
rajouter de nouvelles productions
d'énergie dans le mix énergétique
comment est-ce qu'on vient stocker de
l'énergie pour la rendre plus verte plus
Green et bien meilleure comment est-ce
qu'on vient décarboner enfin bref il y a
plein de solutions qui sont super
intéressantes qu'on voit aujourd'hui ici
à vivatech c'est passionnant c'est un
sujet qui est vraiment passionnant parce
que bien évidemment ça nous touche tous
et ce qui est génial est-ce qu'il faut
en plus venir retenir ici c'est que EDF
au-delà d'être une entreprise qui
fournit et produit de l'énergie et bien
elle investit dans l'avenir elle cherche
des solutions vertes cherche à améliorer
toute la question du rejet de CO2 donc
voilà c'est vraiment cette vision
d'avenir qui est intéressante et qui se
fait également ici au travers de la tech
on trouve ça super passionnant
d'ailleurs dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez est-ce que vous êtes
surpris moi j'étais extrêmement surpris
je trouve ça génial donc dites moi ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires
et pas nous on se retrouve très bientôt
pour continuer à parler tech et vous
allez voir il y a plein de belles choses
qui arrivent à bientôt Ciao